[Music]
i'm going to tell you a story
long long ago young markiplier made a
video on a channel well i didn't make
the video okay pausing the story story
went wrong i didn't make the video the
video was made by a channel called hot
pepper gaming this was back in 2013
2014 2013 one of those years i ate a
habanero pepper and reviewed a game
called rogue legacy
that led me to this moment right here
there's a few steps i missed in between
in that story but that led me to this
moment right here
playing rogue legacy 2. also this video
is brought to you by epic games if you
want to try this game for yourself click
the link in the description and use code
markiplier on the epic game store for
all your purchases that support me check
out the regular free games that the epic
game store has through the link in the
description as well
all right what
here we go i'm not going to waste any
time so this is rogue legacy 2. it is a
roguelike
game
the time has passed and they have not
returned
estuaries have decayed
the kingdom demands deliverance
sign the contract and your children
self-succeed you the whole concept is
you go into a dungeon
and you die but
your children shall inherit
what you left behind
and this game uh it improves on a lot of
the features of rogue legacy one it's
supposed to like when i played it it was
just as like the controls were just as
crisp
and it was just as fun to play but there
wasn't a lot of features and there were
low levels but that was like
pretty much like a year ago at this
point so they've had a lot of updates
since then
oh yeah
who used the thumbstick
like a chump
okay uh i'm gonna speed through this
this is just all tutorial stuff don't
even worry about it don't worry about
don't put this in
don't put any of this in put some of it
in if it's interesting
ah
bam secret shush go away
mana
mana
that's different from rogue legacy one
before i don't think you could recover
mana with hitting anybody without like a
specific talent
no okay
now we are in the game
you welcome back thanks for joining me
this is rogue legacy so the entire
dungeon is randomly generated every time
you go through unless
you lock it down which is like a
different mechanic where you can
compromise some money to be able to play
through the same thing it's good for
practicing but it's for chumps
the important thing to remember is that
if i die it's not because i'm bad that's
by the design of the game
it's meant to be difficult
because you're meant to slowly improve
not that this is difficult whoa
okay there's some things that i'm not
100 familiar with
oh god oh god
no thank you i got to use my magic more
whoa
yeah
fight y'all
because
it's good to do that
so the whole objective is to go through
these dungeons try not to get hurt at
all ooh
cornucopia
cost 25 resolve she's relevant to reveal
his power be generous to others you know
you have more than you know
incandescent telescope light access
warning we see you you see us
interesting a primer on relics and
resolve relics are artifacts that grant
powerful abilities to the user but
require resolve to wield those with a
strong resolve haven't shown no physical
or mental deficits in combat conversely
those with weak resolve less than 100
have displaying signs of ailing health
there also seems to be a correlation
between the amount of armor a soldier
wore in their resolve those with more
armor were less confident in their
abilities thus had weaker wills and
resolve perhaps we should send our
soldiers out naked
perhaps we shouldn't
okay i like food
i'll go with that
cornucopia health drops restore an
additional eight percent okay but i lose
reselve i don't know what that means
oh i think i see the percentage of it
yeah some enemies can pierce through
walls some cannot
oh god i forgot oh geez i did rogue
legacy i thought if i drop attack oh
that's intentional i wanted to get rid
of it because i'm an [ __ ]
no no
what
just like that
so as i go through this dungeon i'm
picking up gold and i'm picking up food
to replace
no
and i'm picking up food to replenish my
health but it doesn't come that often
what is that twin freon's reward all
poisons have their uses some more than
others
an honorable
i don't know that sounds good i already
have that i'll do this one because it
seems cool
hey
what is it opening chest for sore health
that's kind of dope
oh this i know this
oh
okay
i remember that one
leather weapon okay yeah and you it's
like also got rpg elements to it so you
can get upgrades and stuff but you can
only get them after you die
uh what is how do i yeah so there's a
chest at the end of this but i don't
know if that's worth it i'm not really
too interested in the chest right off
the bat
oh god
oh god
oh my god
no not today
oh
it's it's just
so dicey sometimes
oh
it's so dicey on like what will
the only reason i want this is because
there might be some goodies there
in these uh
literally that's the only reason and i
lost most of it on the spikes because
i'm an idiot whatever
somewhere around here there's a boss
there's also certain enemies that can't
uh
drop down from ledges
you'll just have to remember that
easy
easy
easy
easy
so as i say it's randomly generated but
there's like randomly generated template
rooms so some of the rooms are always
the same not in the same position though
that's really the determining factor
oh
what is that
whoa
oh i think i know what this is it's like
some kind of a challenge another soul
has come to roost you seeking my power
right well let me tell you something
kiddo i see all beyond lies beyond ego
beyond time i see the apex of emotions
where truth is laid bare and you know
what i see when i look at you i see a
scared little soul with snot coming out
your nose and poop coming out your butt
you know if you're this ugly on the
outside and let's what's it look like on
the ins
huh interesting how many people you got
in there kiddo well i don't know what
game you're playing but i won't stop you
from taking my challenge word of advice
i have the power of empathy use it about
the trials listen to those who have
fallen before you learn from their
failures and maybe just maybe you'll
have a fighting chance
yeah this is like some custom challenge
that if i fail i die
but i think i can do it
i think i can do it
i can't oh yes i can
that's handy
okay lost again everything i've every
path i've taken is wrong he gives you
only two choices always hides a third ah
[Laughter]
that's fun whoa
been down here for hours not sure what
to do obstacles or just hidden
opportunities what the elder oh could i
use yeah i can
easy peasy
easy peasy
easy peasy my elders are a bunch of
babies
not too afraid to go forward with
what's right in front of you
all right i'm a little worried
oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh
okay okay okay so far so good
what's my elders gotta say about this
there's a nightmare ahead the elders
said they are powerful nihilistic
thoughts that have grown and festered
violence begets violence if i attack or
cast oh i know what that is yeah so
i'm not gonna do it but if i attack at
all
it's uh not happy about me
that's what happens
no
no
that's why i have dash
weee
one can accomplish with kindness
wouldn't one cannot with force if i can
reach the nightmare ahead of me perhaps
i can calm it down
maybe i can
hey
good
hey
i don't need it because i'm so good
oh god oh i for oh no
oh god okay okay okay
okay hang on
well
okay oh wait i can calm them down i
forgot
that's a whole thing
yeah there we go okay i cannot calm this
one down
okay
ah damn it damn it
oh my god
okay
what if i just
seriously what if i oh oh ow ow okay
i'm smarter than you okay
yep turn off
hey
ow god damn it i can't i'm so close
okay
am i near
oh he's mad okay okay okay
ah shoot
he's easy
easy easy easy easy easy easy easy did i
do it
i did it
my ancestors can get wrecked okay
emotional connection with your enemy i
know you'll who you'll be dustin with
you should know
power of
empathy well that's handy
rp to read memories and calm nightmares
that's good
that's good okay only slightly
detrimental
i miss him there hello who are you
hi
another bearer of aesop's tome a word of
caution traveler be mindful what you
learn the truth can be misleading
okay all right see you
wait there's a red uh
red thing here
oh i can finally read these how many
years has it been since we first came
down here fifty a hundred a thousand my
patience is at its end these scholars
they jump from one fancy to the next
like they're the belle of the ball just
singing and dancing and never finishing
anything they started they've taken our
gifts of life and have been and abused
it this lackadaisical behavior must be
brought to an end they must be punished
only through the pain can we describe
discovery i brought this off before but
the others never agree with me they
never do i'll bring it up once more at
the meeting but this time it will be
different i can feel it everyone's
patience has a limit and something tells
me the 13th time will be the charm
oh i'm sure i think this just goes to
another area
ah
requires aether's wings yeah i i don't i
don't have those so there's different uh
biomes in the game and they all have
unique enemies and all the yada yada but
i'm not ready to go there because the
enemies can get tougher
a lot tougher
it does behoove you to
try to discover
everything that's
around
like going every nook and cranny
nice
almost full health that's not
common
wish that did more damage
oh my god what is that
that's a higher level something
no thank you oh my god no
whoo
missed by that much whoo
nope
not the day oh
no
molten oh no
there you go there you go i don't know
what that is but i like it
oh my god
you too huh you too what does this do oh
it's a shield
okay
there's also different classes of
characters that you can play but i'll
get to that when i die which will be
never because i'm good
ah come on
god i wish i had midair dash
boy that'd be handy
hey oh
yeah
ah
here it is
wubbum
so this is the balls
now am i ready for the boss probably not
thrown oh they're sealed that's right
ah
oh
oh i need midair dash
i can't even fight the boss
now the thing is i don't really know if
i'm gonna get emitter dash
that's a teleporter
oh is this another channel ah
interesting
sweet child the anunnak of the shawl
okay
power of momentum
all right another heirloom
what do we have oh i'm dumb
right into the goop
mm-hmm
dash this is how you get it okay this is
what i wanted okay thank you
very good very good oh god oh god oh god
oh god
i see i see
oh this ain't good
yeah sometimes you whoa
yeah
yeah
easy
that was just luck
okay
oh my god
i should have been better about that
what am i doing here i see
uh-huh
okay easy easy easy easy
like nothing
like it weren't nothing so the one thing
i could say about this game for certain
is that like when it comes to just like
fun it's great but the fact that there's
pretty much
near infinite replayability makes it
just
just a fantastic game i love it it's so
fun
i can dash in the air now
all right well now i can go to the
boss i don't know full health and i'm
the just because i get here does not
mean that i'm going to be able to get it
uh because
you i mean
i just you know
it is what it is
you'll see what i mean
in just a moment this boss is um the
bosses in this game are
they don't joke around very much and i
don't really remember exactly what he
does
oh god here he goes no that's easy
what is it what are you doing
that's what you do
oh god
not today
and they have so much health
that's new
no it's not new no definitely oh my god
yeah without any way to get health back
it uh makes it pretty whoa
oh ah right into it
oh there i go and that's it
and that's my journey
but i shouldn't be embarrassed about
that and i'm not
i'm not embarrassed because my heirs are
here
so this is where the rest of the game
really comes in if you're playing this
game
and you're using code markiplier through
the link in the description below then
uh you just because you die doesn't mean
that you start over from the beginning
you pick a new heir who has different
unique traits
you have a home
literally universal health stare
healthy populous working matrix don't
give gold modifiers okay
triage for all your kingdom has granted
its people access to healthcare and
services and amenities certain traits
now give gold bonuses
and then you upgrade your
house to unlock new classes which are
randomly picked there's a bunch of
classes you can get a random selection
in your heirs basically your children
and i unlocked no
i don't want to switch to the ranger
class
i'm good thank you
okay blacksmith yes smithery is open
now i can pay for that enchantress sure
uh
sage totem gain permanent bonuses for
dying okay
dummy i don't need that fashion chamber
max weight capacity how about just
vitality up good max hp
valkyries barbarians and mages well why
not
beards are mandatory
yeah okay i also didn't use my shield at
all i think that does probably get rid
of all damage but i don't know architect
nah
can't afford it what can i afford this
i've upgraded i didn't leave any money
left to buy anything else hi
thanks for helping i ain't got a lot to
my name but i promise your investment in
this year black smitheree will pay off
okay blueprints i didn't leave any money
i didn't leave any money for it god damn
it i would love that
but i can't hi
behold i am the sage totem you're not
bound to me all your knowledge will be
housed within my spirit would the game
mastery in one profession is to gain
advantage and all what we share
knowledge makes us strong that is all
are you still here i'm about to die a
little better
uh
okay
hi
hello
hello my name is lady quinn and i'm
excited to meet you i'm a living dummy
and i know everything about weapons and
stuff
sorry for the starter i'm feeling shy
okay well nice talking to you nice
talking to you too
thank you very much i gotta go
goodbye hello
one must pay the toll you can't take any
gold with you
you must
get rid of all your gold going into this
thing so you have to spend it each time
you go in
so now
i'm back in the same castle same biome
different layout
the golden doors won't open until all
the estuaries have gathered that is all
that lies between us and freedom if i
can open it i can fix everything i can
save everyone oh hi
the throne room doors are currently
sealed
thanks
oh god damn you
oh my god
damn you you are
really messing up my steez
huh
that was not worth it i should have just
ran away i was hoping to get some money
or something
oh hey buddy
oh what
i forgot that i have new spells with
this guy what is that
what is that
hey
maybe i should shield
oh
oh
nice
hey that was a good bit of gold oh i'm a
gambler that's right i'm a compulsive
gambler it's something that probably to
do with
what
what is
puzzle challenge time limit 15
oh god
all right
uh let's go
where's this going oh
oh no no thank you
ah that's not good
all right let's try this one
oh god damn it
oh ah come on
oh come on
this run is not going well for me
that's why i gotta get better about
using the shield which i never do
[Music]
oh ah meant to use my shield but i did
not that's why i gotta get better about
using the shield which i never do
oh hell yeah
okay at least i got some gold this run
so that when i eventually die and fall
flat on my face it won't be so
embarrassing for my heirs
why didn't you leave us anything father
i was terrible at my job
all right this is interesting
oh
oh my god oh whoa
what the hell was that
oh oh i'm falling i i fell i i fell far
haha
99
oh hi
increase match hp by 35
i need this more than i need that
unfortunately i would but that's 69
damage i would be one hit away from
death
and that's not where i would like to be
oh what is that high gain a blessing of
wisdom
okay
i don't know the you can damage yourself
we'll always
oh my spell got replaced eyes not good
i think it's a i think it's a grenade
it's like a bomb
oh let's test it out oh
oh that's cool
okay i'm into that oh hello
now i can take this
excellent thank you
ah man not a lot of drops in this run
not much chicken
sure would love some chicken
oh no no man
oh god
ah
71
oh i thought you were dead
damn the crit effect it really made it
seem like you were dead
oh
chicken
i've not been getting any food
i'm wasting away
please
hello
i am an estuary hand chosen of our king
we are the pinnacle of royalty and by
the king's decree all others shall stand
below us yet here i said rotting in the
halls after my fellow estuaries banished
me from the table me of all table from
the people me the table meet
people
[Music]
oh god i keep thinking one's dead and
it's not
uh i'm in trouble i do not have nearly
enough health for this what was in here
why is it still a question mark
what i already got it
oh god
okay okay
oh god don't
that would not have been okay
ah
i'm by the skin of my teeth here but i
got a lot of money so that'll do for my
eventual death and resurrection
is handy
you're not gonna do anything just gonna
stand there and take it all right fine
by me
well that looks dangerous um let me go
up here real quick and see
because if i mess up once and get by
that i'm
i'm kind of dunzo
oh my god i thought i didn't need to
press jump but oh my god oh god not you
you look dangerous get hit get hit get
hit
okay what's above me what's above me
okay we're fine it's fine hi
oh god
for a second there i was like i knew it
wasn't gonna fall
down the ledge but i just
have this weird feeling gonna do three
three three all right whatever
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god i'm gonna die
okay
there's a path down right below there
i'm gonna take that one
uh
okay oh hi
oh what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do don't do it
okay that yeah okay oh god oh god okay
that's different
oh my god oh my god oh my god don't
don't don't
don't
don't
[Applause]
do they never go away oh my god yeah
excel
[Applause]
what's happening no
oh no oh no
i shouldn't have gone up ah
[ __ ]
i don't even get
fungal spread
i'll be a mage
but death is part of the experience this
game is super fun i just i really really
truly enjoy this game a lot it is just a
delight oh i have even less health okay
i got that
scholar helm vitality of
leather u i might as well just get the
leather stuff because i there's some
like leather unity i don't really know
what it means
lifesteal room there we go now i can get
health back from hitting enemies now the
only problem is i don't know how this
guy works at all i know he's got like
spell okay spells
okay fungal spread oh weird
oh that's a fun one whoa
okay
oh
all right this could be fun i might be
into this okay
i'm back hey there's a chicken god if
only i could get that before
so you're next in line to sign the
contract everything in the name of duty
i presume never stop to think of what
you might be losing well if you're
looking for the treasure you'll have to
find the king's children first can't get
through the door otherwise i've tried
okay thanks buddy real helpful sure
you're not
secretly a bad guy
hey
ho ho
damn he exploded
this might be cool
yeah
hey okay so it explodes on the dot
so it travels through enemies and then
explodes where the dot hits it goes
through walls
that's very handy
very handy okay and i've never really
tried mage before but it's not bad
get out magic the only problem is i have
no health
i have literally 95 health which means
that i get to take like one shot and
then i'm dead
yeah i don't know why i'm not using that
more
i am a mage i should use my spells
oh ah wrong way
oh whoa what i aimed it
i didn't know i could do that
buy them
give me your mana
bongos wardrobe signal to the people to
take arms there will be no quarter for
those who hide lotus stem longer you
than you longer than me the lotus flower
will outlive us all that sounds fun like
black lotus block up to two attacks
consumes 100
that's a change of pace
oh you stupid thing huh
oh god oh my god
i get one hp from killing enemies
i got wasn't that i thought i thought i
just got didn't i just get like
i thought i just got food
no
no no
no no
stop
stop stop stop spinning
stop spinning
oh god no the stupid from behind god
damn it
please don't do this to me i don't want
to lose this soon
oh there's just some nuances to the
class that i'm not 100
used to yet come on food
[Music]
food no
hey
now
well that was embarrassing
i'll do mage again i was enjoying that
and i will do better this time because i
won't have as little health as i did
that time
i didn't get any upgrades so i gotta
i've barely got anything i can't afford
oh there we go all right
let's go
thanks ten percent of my gold stays in
the safe so i get a little a little bit
extra going on and i can upgrade that
over time but i just wanted to get back
in quickly because i'm gonna
i'm gonna do a lot better than i did
before
okay my spells don't forget about the
spells oh that's a fun one
oh
it is difficult to aim right that that's
above me okay
you get different spells each time too
nice fart balls i did like that
yes please
thank you
i'll take it yeah the tesla thing was
nice and all i can't get oh yes i can
god please no not like this i don't like
this
come on
bouncing like that
it's like the vhs thing hidden at the
exact corner of the screen
jerk
bam
oh my god wait what did i have what i
think i had like a relic or something
save me
oh all the gold
i just want to get back to the boss
again letters old but carefully
preserved jay the rumors are true the
golden doors are real and i found them
the door will only open when all the
estuaries have gathered together i know
it sounds crazy but i have a plan to
save everyone but i can't do it myself i
need your help and some people i can
trust that's in short splay around here
there's no one to trust
i'm good at this game i'm good at this
game
i'm trying to prove that i'm good at
this game can i not get over there
oh here oh
oh god
i'm getting real try hard about it you
guys know how i am about doing this and
talking
doing things that actually take some
effort and talking it's uh
they're conflicting skills
i don't have that much in my brain
to be able to do both
oh my god
why
your fire is puny
hey
nice
leather chest thank you
so like the game is just like a a
constant climb of progression and i do
enjoy that a lot it's it makes it very
interesting ooh body buffet
lotus petal if you're not picky
everything could be delicious okay
if he did enemies aye
that'll help me out i'm not at the boss
but it'll help me out for here
oh
interesting
yes more health please
oh no this is not where i want to be
nope i'm out of here ah here it is get
my bonus pity gold
all right
let's do this
okay
all right here we go
let's try this again
okay we got this
probably not though
okay
oh god not i didn't expect that one to
be that
don't do it
you would never
you wouldn't hit a guy with glasses
would you
oh god oh my god
well i
for some reason i thought i had double
jump for a moment there which uh nah i
don't turns out
wow
try me [ __ ]
come at me bro
miss
me don't know if that does anything
better
you have so much health it's not fair
okay okay okay
oh god i might get hit by this nope not
today
oh yeah
oh okay now that i've got a read on his
okay he's got phase two of course
because they always do
not today whoa hey whoa what is that
about
whoa hey whoa okay guys
yeah
please
what is it oh okay
couldn't tell what he was doing at first
whoop
okay
oh god
oh god
oh my god
oh god get up oh frick
if i lose now i'm gonna be real oh god
oh
not today
get farted on [ __ ]
okay
oh god don't hit me
hey
yes
yes
take that you
[ __ ] eat my dust
all right so if you thought that was the
end of the game but it's not that is the
first boss of six
and you have to beat them all
not sequentially thankfully because i
think once you beat it in a run
that boss is beat for good in the castle
but the mage is shockingly pretty good
hey what's up
thank you for putting sure islamic to
the rest regardless of what he's done he
deserved a warrior's death sure let's go
with that all right so that is all the
time i have for this game i love this
game it's something that i've played a
ton at least the first one and this one
is just like
it's got a lot more refinement than the
first game and there's a lot to enjoy
about it it's still technically in early
access but there's so much more content
than there was when i first played which
was almost as much as there was in the
first uh rogue legacy now i'd be willing
to bet there's probably more content and
more replayability in there than the
first rogue legacy link is in the
description thank you everybody so much
for watching remember to use my code
markiplier on the epic game store on any
purchase not even just this game and
thank you all so much for watching and
as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you